There was trouble in the air.
I left you the other day with Henry Clay,
sloshing down some brand in
a late night and mid January,
1850 to try to come up with
ways of solving the great
political challenges they
faced between the sections and
over the expansion of slavery.
They were doing this in great part
because gold had been discovered in
California.
This is an original photograph
of panners gold miners,
white,
Asian,
and who knows probably
somebody mixed black.
If California wasn't ready for statehood
in 1850 it's possible that wouldn't
have needed to be a compromise of 1850
but it was an already and its inception.
People realized how big California was
and they already realize north and south
that part of it was north of the Missouri
compromise line and part of it was
south.
Would that vast territory of California
become a free state or a slave state?
The south greatest spokesman.
It's intellectual leader of its state
sovereignty and states' rights position
delivered what became known quickly that
year as the southern address and in in
Calhoun said many things
warning the country what the
south might do or at least
the deep south might do, but he captured
it in this ending of the speech.
If you,
and he's pointing to northerners
who represent a stronger portion,
cannot agree to settle on the broad
principle of justice and duty.
Say so and let the states
we both represent agreed to
separate and pardon piece.
If you are unwilling we should part
piece tell us so and we shall not and we
still know what to do.
When you reduce the question
to submission or resistance.
If you remain silent you will compel us
to infer by your acts what you intend.
In that case,
California will become the test question.
If you admit her under all the
difficulties that oppose her admission,
you compel us to infer that you intend
to exclude us from the whole of the
acquired territories of the west with
the intention of destroying irretrievably
the equilibrium between the two sections
and one of the oldest ideas
in our political culture
is the great conflict comes
when there's an issue around which
two sides. Let's assume there too.
Sometimes they're more than two,
but if there are two sides
on a great issue of conflict,
one,
one side or the other
cannot accept the result.
When a vital interest is somehow it's
stake that they will not or cannot or
choose not to accept a political outcome.
That's the question and the 1850s can
compromise some kind of coalition and
consensus around this
question of slavery is future
future in the west future in
the American political culture,
future within the constitution
can some kind of center hold.
Now,
clay invited down there,
Webster to deal with this cause Webster's
happens to the most at that point in
time down,
your Webster was the most famous
northern Whig politician.
He was from abolitionist,
Massachusetts. He was antislavery.
They'll never a card carrying
abolitionists to say the least.
He was a great lawyer. Many said the
greatest order in the United States.
Those were usually the ones that
hadn't heard Frederick Douglass yet.
He'd been in Congress since
1823 almost as long as clay.
He'd been in the Senate since 1844 he
was seen in some ways is the lion and the
spokesman of New England.
He had been the great voice and the
nullification crisis debates of 1830
he had been a voice of union,
but also law enforcement. Then,
that famous phrase that did,
he had become known for liberty in
union now and forever one and separable.
Webster always seem to be the union man.
At the same time.
He was an anti slavery man.
Henry Clay from Kentucky,
founder of the Whig Party candidate for
president three and four times over the
organizational genius in some ways
behind the Whig party and it's so called
national system.
The idea of using government for economic
and social change in the lives of
immigrants and everybody else.
Clay of Kentucky slave holder,
he owned about 60 people,
hemp plantation farmer,
original founder of the
American colonization society,
a border state,
political titan with great
influence in the congress.
Okay.
Polls in Webster and
says web to were Daniel.
We've got to save the Union cause liquid
Calhoun and company in the deep south
or threatening. What will we
do? How will we solve this?
I mentioned the other day that when
clay introduced his five measures,
which were known first is
the claim measures and then
as the compromise measures,
he stood up in the Senate with great
theater and held a piece of what he said
with George was George
Washington's coffin.
What were the issues in 1850?
Uh,
I hope you've seen enough of the outline.
If not, it's gone for the moment.
The issues that are on the map,
I think I need to,
no, they told me that makes it
better. Okay. That's better.
I guess the issues are the California
and the West is ready for statehood
overnight because of that vast
migration of minors by sea,
by land and by imagination.
It always been a brewing issue in the
u s congress and in the district of
Columbia about the fact that
the district of Columbia,
the Capitol of the United States,
was a slave trading center.
Northern Congressmen of all stripes had
always been bothered by the fact that
about two and a half blocks
down the street from the
United States capitol was a
huge slave jail.
People said that when the wind was right,
you could smell it on
the steps of the capitol.
Abraham Lincoln and his one term in the
house, call it a human livery stable.
Foreign visitors would
come and they would say,
they would stand in awe at that majestic
capital as it was being built in.
The Dome was being completed
and then they would ask,
where's the slave jail?
Can we see a slave jail?
So there were a lot of northerners.
Now we're saying, okay,
this is gonna be some big
compromise now about California,
but slavery in the West.
What we're gonna do about this.
Let's deal with this question too.
Yeah.
Thirdly,
there was the question of,
and this is what southerners were
exorcized about a fugitive slaves escaping
into the north.
And that's so cold underground railroad
and the term underground railroad
appears for the first time openly over
and over in public debate on the floor of
the u s congress, southern
standing up and saying, we need a,
a much stronger federal fugitive slave
act requiring the return of fugitive
slaves because they are escaping too
much in that underground railroad.
They didn't have a clue
what it really was,
didn't matter.
But southerners wanted fugitive slaves,
retrieved to them by law
under federal enforcement,
no questions asked.
And then there was the problem of Texas.
Now, uh, it doesn't quite show
it on this map properly, but,
uh, the other day you
remember the map of Texas,
the boundaries of Texas had never
been determined to the Mexicans,
much less to the Americans.
And the idea here now was to how,
how would you kind of divide up Texas?
There was no New Mexico or Arizona yet.
It's just this vast territory
called the New Mexico territory.
The idea was if you moved back the border
of Texas about three or 400 miles and
you placed it where it actually is today,
you would open up new territory.
Lots of it to the establishment of at
least one new if not two new. Yeah.
Okay.
And those states in the
southern imagination would
in all likelihood be slave
states.
They were southern
more to do with the Texas boundary.
Now,
Daniel Webster supportive.
This came at some price.
It came at a huge price
for his own career.
The five measures that came out of
their discussions, they weren't alone,
but they really did conceive of this.
The five parts of the compromise of 1850
okay,
we'll be on your citizenship test.
You shouldn't have US citizenship if
you can't name the five parts of the
compromise of 1850 I've
always believed that.
And the three parts of the
Kansas, Nebraska, that should
be a test of citizenship.
No Lithuanian should ever
get us citizenship without
being able to name the five
parts of the compromise of 1850 nevermind.
California would be admitted
as a free state. Clay said,
there's no way around this.
If they hold a referendum in California,
it's going to be a free state. The people
who have gone there are all, you know,
they're all little people.
They're all these, you know,
these miners and these panners there.
They're immigrants.
They're people from Germany who have
come across the see all in one year to go
find a Golden California.
They're not going to be slave holders.
Yeah.
All right. California will
be admitted as a free state,
but now remember what Calhoun had said,
so what are you going to give the south?
Yeah,
and return.
The South is going to get a whole new,
much stronger federal,
fugitive slave act.
The most notorious and controversial
aspect of the compromise of 1850
secondly, clay said, Webster,
let's abolish the slave. In
the district of Columbia,
we have,
we have federal jurisdiction over that.
The congress has jurisdiction over the
district. Let's abolish the slave trade.
Let's get this slave
jails out of Washington.
Northern has all like that
rubs. Just said, yeah,
let's move the boundary back three, 400
miles. It was really about 350 miles.
Let's open up a whole new part of
the Mexican cession to the possible
establishment of new slave states.
Let's let southerners dream of two and
three more states and four to six more US
senators in the next three to five years.
Let's let them feel secure that California
may come in as a free state and get
two new senators and the number will
now be 16 to 15 free to slave states.
People were counting,
but the idea was, yeah,
but maybe the south gets two or
three other Mexicans session.
And then lastly,
how would slavery be determined
in that southwest the big issue?
How do you do it?
By what principle?
Probably said popular sovereignty.
Let the people have a referendum and vote
liberal democracy.
So that statehood for any
territory and the Mexican cession,
uh,
except for California here,
this is the stuff of compromise.
Don't look for hard principles here
except for California.
Everything else in the Mexican session
will be determined on popular sovereignty.
The people who settled the territory at
some stage of the territory of process
could be,
or it could be late,
we'll vote whether slavery shall exist,
so I'll look at the five measured.
California will be a free state
slave trade trade,
not slavery itself will be abolished
in the district of Columbia.
Two issues.
The North Wall like
okay,
the Texas bound removed back open to new
territory. New possible southern states.
Yeah,
and that fugitive slave act two,
two measures.
Southerners would really like,
and by the way,
when clay suggestion of the fugitive slave
act to Webster, Webster says, no, no, no,
I can't take that home to Massachusetts
at won't fly. You can't do that.
Clay said you have to do that. We'll
have just said, I can't do that.
Clay said you have to do that. Have
some more branding. Webster said, okay,
I don't know how much brand do they drink
and popular sovereignty is of course
it's American democracy. Let them vote.
It's, it's an appeal to both sides,
two for each side and one for everybody.
It is a great compromise in sense,
but how has it actually passed is crucial.
Of course,
it's substance is crucial the way it was.
Finally,
path is the [inaudible],
and by the way,
there was no certainty
whatsoever that this would work.
After clay initiated the debate
with an emotional appeal for union,
Daniel Webster spoken what became known
in his career and in American history is
the 7th of March speech.
He held forth for three hours and
one of his classic Philippics.
It began with the famous
lines I wish to speak today,
not as a Massachusetts man, Norris
and northern man, but as an American.
I speak today for the
preservation of the union.
Any appeal to his fellow northerners,
the vote for the fugitive slave to
vote to make northern states legally
complicit in the return of fugitive
slaves in their neighborhoods.
He got groans and he got
jeers and he got cheers.
Everybody said one of the
greatest speeches ever made
in the u s senate and it
ruined Webster's career.
Poets started writing about as Whittier
did the devil and Daniel Webster.
Calhoun was unable to deliver.
His speech was the 4th of March.
Uh, he was too sick. He
will be dead by the fall.
It was delivered by James Mason.
His colleague
Calhoun was carried into the u s
Senate in a chair. He couldn't walk.
They literally carried him in,
sat him down.
He stared at his shoes on.
Mason delivered his speech
in which Calhoun said that
the south had to stand now
as one for a slave society and for states'
rights and for the protection of what
he constantly argued were minority rights.
Okay.
Calhoun's speech, arguably, I think
from an interpretive mode now,
frightened,
especially some northern into voting
for a compromise they hated it.
May have even frightened some
border state Democrats and wigs
to vote for this thing,
some of which they hated,
like any great compromise them.
And you've ever been on major political
committees, dorm committees and so on.
You got to pass something, but you got
two or three things on the, on the bill,
and are these people who hate number,
item number one, and these people eight.
Item number two and these people,
eight. Item. Number three,
what happens if you vote on
all three at the same time?
Everybody's got something to vote against.
So the way the compromise of 1850 was
passed and it was passed largely by the
young Steven,
a Douglas who took over the management.
He's about 38 years old at this point.
Senator from Illinois, uh, young Titan,
small as he was five foot six,
a young tighten over the
Democratic Party from Illinois.
He was really the parliamentary manager
in the midst of the debates from
March into the summer of 1850.
There were threats of disunion
from southerners every other day,
brave threats and newt assistant,
southern newspapers.
So a Douglas dead is a classic
parliamentary maneuver.
He voted on each bill separately and
ultimately called it the omnibus bill.
And in each case,
manage just enough of a narrow majority,
getting enough northerners,
especially northern Democrats,
to vote for that fugitive slave act,
which they tended to hate.
And then Justin enough southern,
what's left of the wigs to vote for the
end of the slave trade and the district
of Columbia.
And it passed in early August,
1850 Henry Clay ill,
terminally sick,
had gone home to Kentucky,
maybe out of the picture
and out of American history
before the end of the year.
Calhoun was dying at that very moment
was dead, I believe by September
Webster was now to be
denounced politically forever
and his own political party
and in his own Massachusetts,
but the compromise past and in some ways
the nation celebrated or so it's seen
the compromise of 1850 did
in some ways save the union,
at least at that point in time.
But as David Potter,
the, the bestest story into this
we've ever had said it was far more,
and it's the best way to remember it.
I think it was far more in armistice
than it really was a compromise.
It began to collapse almost
as fast as it passed.
There were huge rallies and marches in
northern cities celebrating the saving of
the Union. People were frightened, I
mean business interests in the north,
not just in New York City
where the banks all were,
but now in this colossus of Chicago,
this burgeoning railroad center
in the West. And Cincinnati,
Detroit worried.
I mean,
what if there is disunion what happens to
the economy? What happens to, to trade?
So there were a great
rallies at the same time,
state of Georgia minutes
legislature by December,
1850 and passed what they
called the Georgia platform
and send it all around the
rest of the deep south.
And it said,
it said the state of Georgia gave only
it's conditional acceptance to the
compromise measures waiting to see
whether the north acted in good faith.
In other words,
we don't trust you.
Some northern state legislature said,
Oh really?
And they passed a resolution saying
we don't think we trust you either.
Yeah.
There were vehement protest
against the fugitive slave act.
The fugitive slave act above all else
in this crisis caused much further
conflict.
It led directly to an estimated
20,000 African American free blacks.
Well free blacks and fugitive slaves.
So many of them living in the northern
states and in some cases whole church
congregations from cities
like Philadelphia and Boston
moved north of the border
into Canada between 1850
and roughly a 1857 58
yeah.
When there was another small wave
after the dred Scott decision,
this will lead to the establishment
and that fugitive slave act of special
federal magistrates whose job
the whose sole job it was.
Now this is a whole new level of,
of,
of federal adjudication
of fugitive slaves.
Magistrates were now appointed to go
all over the north to retrieve fugitive
slaves.
Well,
just set up a police apparatus to retrieve
fugitive slaves and then the conduct
courts to determine their identity.
And in the fugitive slave act itself,
it determined,
or it's said that those magistrates
would be paid twice as much money.
They actually would be paid $10 for every
fugitive slave they convicted of being
that person and sent them back to slavery.
And $5 for every acquittal.
No, no, $5 doesn't seem like much.
But on the cert on the face of that,
and you look at that and you ain't no
wait a second, this is blind justice.
You're going to give me twice as much
money to convict you as a [inaudible].
Hey,
I need a meal too.
It led now to famous fugitive
slave rescues like the
rescue of Jerry Mchenry in
Syracuse,
New York in 1851 and a violent rescue by
abolitionists to spirit who killed one
of his captors and
carted him off to Canada.
It led to the rescue of Shadrack
minkins in early 1852 in Boston,
a fugitive slave from Virginia who was
working in an abolitionist coffeehouse in
Boston, retrieved by slave
catchers, taken to a jail,
broken out of that jail.
One of the jailers murdered on the spot
by a mob of abolition is led by Louis
Hayden himself,
a fugitive slave from Kentucky who
lived in Beacon Hill in Boston and dared
federal magistrates to come to his house
and try to retrieve Strad rec minkins
by putting an entire posse on the street
and a keg of gunpowder in front of his
door, which he threatened. He would blow
up if any magistrate garden near it.
And that night they spirited shed
Rakoff to Concord, Massachusetts,
where the descendants of abolitionists
to this day like to argue which hosts he
stayed in and then off cross route to
cross northern Massachusetts and on up
into Canada where shed rec remained the
rest of his life as a grocer in Montreal
and there were many, many other
fugitive slave rescues. Now,
there was the fugitive
slave rescue at Christiana,
Pennsylvania in 1851 it
was really at a farm,
a slave holder named Gorsuch,
and a posse of only five or six men
cornered a group of his former slaves.
Four of them in a barn
group of abolitionists.
Black and white defended them
in a gun bottle in a gun battle.
One of the Gorsuch, his sons was
killed. The future, the slaves escaped.
They ended up going
across upstate New York.
Two of them ended up in
Frederick Douglass, his
house in Rochester, New York.
Douglas drove them personally in a
carriage to the wharf on Lake Erie
and when he bid them goodbye,
one of them gave him the
revolver that he had used it.
Christiana, I'm a Mento. The
Douglas kept the rest of his life.
Resistance to slavery was now
direct,
sometimes violent.
The underground railroad had been
filming over ground railroad.
It was no longer caught up in the romance
of a whole lot of people spiriting
people to secret hideaways.
It was sometimes now a
matter of gun violence
and one could argue that
the most important thing
that happened in the wake of
the fugitive slave act and therefore the
compromise of 1850 was the publication
of uncle Tom's cabin, Harriet
Beecher Stowe, that brilliant,
very short little woman would live for
quite a while with her husband Calvin
stoves,
a theologian teaching in Cincinnati and
lived in a house on a hill in Cincinnati
for several years where
she first met slave women,
where she first met fugitive slaves coming
through Cincinnati may have hit a few,
heard their voices,
tried to learn their dialect,
and wrote the greatest novel of the
19th century and still on any list,
any shortlist of the best selling works
of literature and the history of the
world.
That sugarcoated antislavery
story of several characters.
Eliza young allies,
a light skinned where their babies gaping
across the Ohio jumping from iceberg,
the iceberg iceberg.
They,
Ohio doesn't have icebergs anymore.
Didn't have any of that either.
Okay.
Our uncle Tom Himself,
the most important Christ like
figure in all of American literature.
Harriet Stowe wrote a brilliant book,
whatever I want and anyone
wants to say about it,
she made everybody complicit in
complicit as in the slave story.
The most despicable character in the book
is Miso Phelia who was born in Vermont,
who's racist to the core,
who can't stand black people and goes
down south preaching at southerners.
What's wrong with slavery? At the same
time, just can't get near black people.
And in some ways,
the most admirable character in
that book was a southern slaveholder
and actually the most evil character,
the most heinous characters,
missile field yet, but the most evil
character. Of course, it's Simon legree
and Simon legree was
himself from New England.
The whole world was suddenly reading
a work of fiction about slavery.
It's so 300,000 copies in the first year
by far broke every sales record
of any book ever published,
ever anywhere
reprinted into at least to 20 languages.
And its first five years of existence
made into stage plays within two years.
Okay.
It brought an awareness to the
slavery problem as never before.
And then the election,
the congressional off year elections
of 1852 four every four votes for every
four votes cast for Franklin Pierce,
the Democrat who will win
one copy of uncle Tom's cabin sold
somewhere in the United States.
I mean name a book today that we
could even imagine doing that.
What did they are worth?
A novel
that are electric was
electrified by in some way
now
in the wake of the Kansas and excuse me,
in the wake of the compromise of 1850
the country now though had to face this
question, not just what'd you going to
do with the Mexican cession territory's.
That's going to take a little while.
Northerners,
a lot of northerners are pissed off about
the nature of the Utah Territory Bill
and in New Mexico territory bill.
Cause there are southerners immediately
propose a slave territories for Utah and
New Mexico.
But the real question by 1853 and early
854 was all the territory that was left
of the Louisiana purchase,
the Kansas and Nebraska territories,
which is simply what they
were at that point in time.
Now it is worth stopping for a moment to
realize that not every American woke up
in 1850150250 three you're worried every
moment of every day about the expansion
of slavery.
They are worried about it.
And it proves to us without question
that there was a political crisis,
a brewing that the electric cared about.
Okay?
But it's worth remembering that a lot
of Americans were preoccupied with the
same things. They always work.
Price of wheat, a sick cow,
wages at a textile mill,
a son who wants to marry him,
needs land.
A daughter wants to marry an Irishman
or, uh, most of all,
all those Catholics arriving in
New York City and Philadelphia,
huge numbers of Irish Catholics.
They're going to Catholicized America.
They're going to turn every,
every small outhouse into a confessional.
We laugh today.
It's easy to laugh at this,
but nativism caught hold in the
early 1850s more on this a bit later.
Um,
with the breakup of the American party
system as we take it through the 1850s
but a lot of Americans were really
worried about those Catholics,
but the Kansas Nebraska Act or the
establishment now of the territory's of
Kansas and Nebraska and what to do with
them was front and center on the agenda
of the United States Congress by late
1853 in the wake now of numerous of these
celebrated violent rescues
of fugitive slaves.
The attempts to enforce the fugitive
slave act in some parts of the north where
it was very successfully prosecuted and
dozens and dozens and dozens of fugitive
slaves were returned to the south.
But in some celebrated cases,
they weren't
quickly.
The most celebrated case of all came
in the spring of 1854 at the time,
Congress is debating this thing called
the Kansas Nebraska act and people are
politically waiting with bated breath
and if I find out what are they actually
going to do here?
We had the rescue in Boston have a
fugitive slaves name. Anthony Burns,
who was a young guy in his early
twenties he had escaped out of Virginia,
Boston by sea.
He too was working in a actually a
store at one point a coffee shop.
At another point he was even distributing
copies of William Lord Garrison's
liberate her and been there even a
year and a slave catchers found him,
captured it.
Now after Shad Rec minkins got out of
Boston in 1852 the Anthony Burns rendition
case capture the imagination of
the nation because Franklin Pierce,
president of the United States move
federal troops about 3000 of them into the
streets of Boston to guard the courthouse
and the guard the jail and make sure
nobody broke Anthony Burns out.
It became a test case for the
Democratic Party of Massachusetts. Yes,
and on the day Anthony Burns was marched.
He was convicted,
marched from the jail down to the wharf
and put on the ship back to slavery in
Virginia,
the abolitionists community,
black and white of Boston and all
of Massachusetts gathered in Boston.
They held an all night
vigil with candle light,
but outside of the jail and they drape
the streets of Boston or some of the
streets and black crepe in the morning.
Burns was sent back to Virginia.
It's his story is amazing though.
Is owner then sold him.
It was to a famous sold in
the North Carolina and one
day a white woman in North
Carolina wrote a letter
to her sister in Amherst,
Massachusetts and said,
Helen,
that slave name Burns that
they captured up in Boston.
He's living on the farm next door.
Isn't that interesting?
And her sister wrote from the
first Baptist Church of mammary,
Massachusetts back to her
sister and said, really, um,
what if we could raise
some money to purchase him?
Would you talk to your neighbor?
She talked to her neighbors.
One thing led to another abolition is
beginning in Amherst, Massachusetts.
And then around the state of
Massachusetts raise the money,
made the offer and Anthony
Burns freedom was sold.
And you came north by 1856
he first arrived in Amherst,
Massachusetts where he was celebrated.
They took him out on the road,
exhibit a and he went to Canada
and he died in 1860
prematurely of disease. Lonely,
lost,
almost unknown.
But it was in that environment.
Now that the congress has to decide
what to do with Kansas and Nebraska now,
here was the situation.
It was in part a big deal because what
was firing the American imagination now
was not just to the west,
but it was the railroad west.
Who would build these railroads?
Where would they be built and where
would this eastern terminus be?
Would there eastern terminus of the
transcontinental railroad being a North
Chicago or maybe St
Louis in a slave state,
or maybe further south in New Orleans,
or maybe Memphis.
Maybe there'd be two of them.
Maybe we can have a
compromised transcontinental
railroad bill. Two of them.
Well then people said,
no way.
I was gonna be hard enough to build
one of them over those mountains.
Okay.
The chairman of the Senate
territory's committee,
very powerful position in these
years was Stephen Douglas.
He's not about 40 years old,
a political genius with
a few terrible flows.
Douglas,
one of the terminus of
the transcontinental
railroad to be in Illinois,
in Chicago,
and to go across the north to the
North West in the northern California.
Douglas is approach to slavery though
is terribly important here it is in some
ways all of the story.
Stephen Douglas believes that the climate
would solve the problems of slavery.
He's famous for all these speeches he
would make where he would say, you know,
often soil is good and the temperatures
are right and then slavery will probably
exist or the soil is not proper
and the temperatures aren't right.
Or if you've got mountains,
slavery won't exist,
climate will solve the problem and
wouldn't that be great? And we did.
We'll just lift them.
All of our great political troubles with
just lifted off our shoulders by the
weather.
Just watch the weather channel
the hell with MSNBC and CNN,
all those blabbering pundits
just watch the weather channel.
He really believed that don't have,
you know,
there was some reason to believe that
no problem was southern is one,
one thing out of this and a lot
of northerners one another thing,
but here was the question,
which principle will you apply about
slavery in the Kansas and Nebraska
territory?
Think now the recent past,
think of the distant past in American
terms to the compromise of 1851 had the
compromise of 1850 already
superseded the Missouri compromise.
Think about that.
You had that sacred bargain.
They said of the 36 30 parallel line
dividing free territory from slave
territory forever pass back in 1820
that was that vow that the northerners
concerned about the expansion of slavery
could always assume the great northwest
would be free of slavery,
but cal,
half of California is below it,
below it and half of it's above.
It had the compromise of 18 and half.
The Mexican session is above it and
now you said popular sovereignty will
determine the Utah territory
and not the Missouri compromise.
So which rule is in play?
Yeah.
Which principle do you apply?
Do you apply?
The oldest principal of the northwest
ordinance of 1787 the northwest ordinance
folks had said slavery shall never
exist in the northwest territory,
which became those five states of
Michigan, Ohio, Indiana, Illinois,
and Wisconsin will never exist.
Explicit territorial exclusion.
That's one principle.
Second principle, geographical
division, Missouri compromise.
Draw a line across the continent.
Do you go back to that one
or do you use the third one now?
The third one that's employee popular
sovereignty. Just let the people choose.
Forget geography.
Forget old laws
and have a referendum.
In other words,
and this,
this is the great question of the 1850s
and the terrible tragedy that in the end
nothing worked. Would the American
pragmatic tradition now, yeah,
we got this.
We got principal ab and C here.
We all want principled politicians.
Don't we want principal professors
and principal politicians,
principled stock brokers?
At the end of the day.
Sometimes the three principles in play,
what American pragmatism
continue to solve. This one,
well maybe that principle is best now,
but that principal is better than
Douglas wrote, the bill, the Kansas,
Nebraska bill as it was called
or act. Now, um,
in this case, folks, numbers matter.
We're going to look at a vote,
but first of all, he wrote three different
versions of the Kansas Nebraska Act.
This is important.
He went from Vegas to most
specific because southerners
put his feet to the fire
and made him do it.
He first introduced a bill in December,
1853 this is for the establishment
of Kansas and Nebraska territory.
Everybody said that's nice. Was that
was doing this to the, you know,
there's millions of acres and square
miles, but it's slavery going to exist.
The first version that he put before
Congress in January four 1854 said that a
state shall be admitted
from those territories,
quotes with or without slavery as their
constitution may prescribe at the time
of admission.
Note the vagueness and you
all know the new politics.
Sometimes the Vagaro you are,
the more you get done.
Slavery,
widow without slavery as
their constitution may
prescribe at the time of their
admission.
How that's to be done was not mentioned.
Douglas said,
leave it to time.
Climate and good sense.
It was silent about the old
Missouri compromise line.
Southerners quickly reacting and said,
Steven,
his own fellow Democrats in the south
that were now dominant in the south said,
nope, not enough. And there were a lot
of powerful southerners in the Senate.
So he drafted six days later,
January 10 of 50 for a second
version of the Kansas Nebraska Act,
and he,
he gave a direct statement
of popular sovereignty quote,
the decision on slavery shall be
left to the people residing there in.
Now he's moved one step further,
so there's going to be a vote
out there and how are they vote?
That'll determine again, his
fellow southerner said, no,
not enough.
And there was a famous episode where
as a kind of spokesman for the southern
point of view,
a Kentucky wig from the other party name
Archibald Dixon took Steven Douglas for
a ride in a carriage one day
in March of 1854 after these,
these uh, excuse me, uh, in late January,
they are going to vote
on it later in March,
but in late January it
took her a carriage ride
and Dixon and no uncertain
terms told Douglas No, no.
What'd you have to do is you have to
draft an explicit repeal of the Missouri
compromise line,
a specific repeal of any
geographic division between
slavery and freedom in the
West. In other words, Steven,
you'd have to open up the entire west
to the possible expansion of slavery.
Douglas didn't want to do that.
He knew this was going to cause a bad
time in the north and he is alleged to
have said back to Dixon quote
by God, sir, you are right.
I will incorporate it in my bill though.
I know it will raise a hell of a storm.
And he was right.
It may seem a bit odd to us today that
Americans could care this much about what
was to be done to Nebraska
or for that matter with Kansas.
We didn't even know about Dorothy
yet and the yellow brick road,
but no other than it was
really did care visit.
Think back again to this idea of Free
Labor radiology and we'll bring this up
again and again and the
next three lectures.
The American dream to the
average northerner immigrant
or not was land free land
of possible cheap land if not a place to
move to mobility where you would never
have to compete with any kind of
oligarchy that could control that land.
The bill that he finally brought forth
and that actually passed had two measures
and I'm going to leave you here.
The two measures were they explicit
repeal of the Missouri compromise line and
the principle of popular sovereignty.
The formula for the settlement
of Kansas and Nebraska.
The Kansas Nebraska Act is arguably the
pivotal event politically of the 1850s
that will now sectionalize American
politics break apart forever.
The Whig party, what was
left of it, and give birth to
the first successful third party
coalition movement in American history.
The Republican Party immediately,
which comes into existence immediately
in the wake of the Kansas Nebraska Act.
And if you want to understand
how sectional that vote
was right down that vote,
count in the house. No Northern
Democrats, but right in half.
That's Douglas as party,
but nearly half of his own party in
the House voted against this bill.
Southern Democrats 57 to two
I can't explain those two.
I don't know what happened to them.
Northern Whigs 45 to zero against this.
This is a polarization folks.
We've heard a lot about that recently.
Southern wigs 12 to seven the
Whig party is diminishing.
It's all, but it will be dead
in the wake of Kansas, Nebraska,
and the four free soilers elected in
1852 now our platform that oppose the
fugitive slave act voted of
course against Kansas, Nebraska,
that vote 113 to 10 got the
Kansas Nebraska Act passed,
but in the long run with terrible results,
it will break apart the
American political party system.
It will bring about for the first time,
a genuine antislavery political coalition
that will elect a president within six
years.
See you on Thursday.